it was always very hard to to get any
kind of acceptance within the Korean
Community for me and then as I got older
too because I also I'm very different I
have a lot of tattoos a lot which is
very controversial in Korean culture to
have them I have a lot
and uh so uh Koreans are very uh they're
they're really against tattoos it's very
taboo for Koreans to have tattoos
because during the Korean War everything
was destroyed and then rebuilt by
organized crime and the way that the
organized criminalized recognized each
other was through their tattoos so it's
real controversial and so I go to the
clothing optional Korean spas in Los
Angeles which are not just clothing
optional everybody's just naked
you know I was naked and I'm just naked
with my tattoos and you know walking
around and Korean people are giving me
dirty looks
which is hard to tell it's hard to tell
when a Korean is giving you a dirty look
you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I felt self-conscious so I went into
like a sauna you know by myself and I'm
just sitting there in the sauna naked
and watching big screen TV just watching
golf
and the manager comes in and she's fully
clothed and she's like uh can I talk to
you out here it's really hot I was like
okay and so I've been standing outside
and she goes I hate to tell you this
but you are really upsetting people here
with your body
I'm going to have to ask you to put your
clothes on
and the thing about me is that I have
it's bush
[Music]
not even a 70s Bush it's like a 1870s
bush
[Applause]
and it absorbs a lot of water
so then when I stood up it was like
and I I was a little bit I didn't know
what to say and then you know he's
looking at me and then I finally I just
said uh do you know who I am
her eyes went from my enormous Bush to
my face and she really said oh my God
you're Margaret Cho I'm a really big fan
I've been to your shows I think you're
amazing but you still have to put your
clothes on
so I was like all right
but this is wrong and you are gonna be
sorry and I just walked away
and I really wasn't sure how they were
gonna be sorry but I was like determined
that they were gonna be sorry that I
went oh and I actually wrote about it
and I posted it online and it it just
kind of went everywhere it was on
Huffington Post and Jezebel and all
these different places and the Korean
spa SATA they they called me they were
so sorry you could hear the Bowing over
the phone like I was so sorry
[Music]
sorry sorry
you're so sorry and they offered me
whatever I wanted for free I could come
back and I could have whatever I wanted
anything I wanted for free but I didn't
want to go because I was very offended
you know I thought that was really wrong
for them to discriminate against against
me you know like I I think it's okay for
people to be freaked up by my looks or
whatever but you can't have the
management say that you should you know
put your clothes on it was wrong so I
was really angry I didn't want to go but
then I talked to my mom about it and she
was like but it's free
[Applause]
foreign